hey everybody thanks for coming back
after lunch I know we all had like lots
of food and wine and stuff
but we're gonna be talking about
something that I find really exciting
this afternoon and hopefully you do too
that the title of this talk is SPG can
do that part of the reason why I'm
giving this talk is because SVG as a
graphics format is just capable of so
much and I think we're just at the tip
of the iceberg for really touching on
all of those capabilities so yeah like I
said my name is Sarah Dresner this is a
photo of me as a child and my mom and my
relationship with Authority
I'm a senior developer advocate at
Microsoft I just started so that's
exciting and I just think SVG is a total
party you can kind of make your party
yourself or you can have JavaScript be
the event coordinator get it event okay
there's gonna be lots of bad jokes where
that came from
and we can do so many cool things with
it so some of you already might know the
benefits of SVG but just in case you
don't let's go over some of those it's
crisp on any display it's built with
math so basically any time you're making
an SVG you're just plotting a few
coordinates and the computer is drawing
all those coordinates out for you so
it's not like bitmaps
where you know if you make something
really big or really small it loses
clarity and it kind of loses pieces of
it so that's really nice it has less
less HD I always mess that part up at
less HTTP requests to handle did it
alright cool
it can have no age to be a request to
handle because you can have it directly
in line unlike other images where you
have to make requests from other sources
as we move into HTTP 2 this is less of
an issue but we're not quite there yet
so for the time being SVG is really
awesome for that it's easily scalable
for responsive one of my favorite things
it's in the name scalable vector
graphics that means that you can make it
adjust to any kind of viewport and well
definitely going to be doing stuff with
that today it's a really small file size
if you design for performance if you
design for performance is an important
part of that so
we'll talk about that today as well it's
easy to animate again one of my favorite
things I wrote a literal book of us hat
it has a navigable Dom which means that
you can reach right inside of it and
move certain pieces around so if you
have a flat image where everything is
just kind of presented in front of you
in order to make an arm move or
something you'd have to go in and cut
out pieces of it in order to you know
kind of move them around these are
literally just Dom nodes that you can
slap classes on that you can do all of
the same things that you do with HTML
elements with so that's really cool we
talked about how it's and now it has a
navigable Dom it also can be accessible
because it has a navigable DOM and it's
fun remember when we used to have fun
fun's cool yeah cool all right so with
all of the Pens that I'm going to be
showing today I I made all of these
demos but I'm gonna be showing you some
work that other people made as well to
kind of showcase them but I'll
definitely have their names at the top
of them and then also I make the slides
open source so you can check them out
later SVG is such a flexible medium we
can do so much with it we can manage
state even with within it and do all
sorts of beautiful effects so I actually
hope that this is the last year I have
to show this slide
people think that SVG is really not well
supported because years past it wasn't
but look at all that green
we got Opera Mini we never get off from
Annie that's just amazing and you know
it says ie 11 there but it actually goes
back to ie 9 with partial support on ie
8 I don't know why can I use doesn't
show you all of that information but if
you're not using SVG because you think
it's poorly supported you can update
that information in your mind as well so
what does the scalable mean when we talk
about scalable vector graphics you can
see here we place the graphic directly
inline in the HTML and it has width and
height attributes which keep it to that
size but then when I take those out it
adjusts and it fills that entire area
which means that if I wanted to you know
make it constrained to the viewport
width
or the viewport height I can do so or if
I want to put it inside of a flexbox
or grid or percentage you name it so
that's really nice because everything
stays totally consistent and is
positioning in CSS keeping you down
sometimes it but it kind of bothers me
SVG might just be your answer you saw
all of those things that were inside of
the SVG we're staying exactly at their
coordinates no matter what we were doing
to it that's really awesome for
positioning you can kind of just throw
all of the like crazy CSS stuff to the
wayside and position things within
SVG it even has text as a side note I
did this to myself on the plane on the
way here I was drinking wine and
watching a horror movie and splashing in
my face anyway SVG allows you to do
create create advanced effects like this
type lock up and it can look really
slick and professional while still using
actual accessible text that's so nice
for Responsive which also means that in
terms of animation we can create
something that's fully responsible and
scalable in every direction and the
animation values are working within that
coordinate system so they'll to stay
totally sits totally stable even if
you're changing the sizes of them and
moving things around and adjusting it
these type of positioning refinements
are really really wonderful if you have
a ton of information on smaller screens
like mobile and you don't want to show
all of the information at once if you
have tons of icons and you need to kind
of collapse that view you can do really
advanced layout effects where you're
showing and hiding that information with
only a small amount of kilobytes so it
doesn't necessarily have to be you know
squishy either we don't just squish
things back and forth when we make
responsive design let's do some real
responsive design so I made a huggy
laser Panda factory because you know we
need to know where huggy laser pandas
come from and that's where they come
from so if we have the huggy laser panda
on desktop we it's actually comprised of
three different SVG's we've got one for
the top part and one for the side and
one for the
other side and then on mobile they're
going to stack and reconfigure you can
see that middle part that one on the
side that's magenta is actually just
being transformed translated and kind of
moving over to the side so if we have
the paint the Panda factory running we
have our Panda getting painted to be a
panda then we have our Panda getting
lasered and then we have our Panda
getting hug heed you know like you have
in real life and then when we scale it
down to mobile everything can kind of
reconfigure and reconfirm and all of
this works on old Android Android
devices old windows phones and it's only
13 kilobytes so if we look into the code
here what we'll actually see is that I
have a timeline that's wrapped in a
function that's named appropriately in
case in this case the naming it
appropriately is like function paint
Panda and I really literally have a
click event listener to reach rigor that
time line but you'll see all of the
functions are scoped to the SVG's itself
so the design and the functions are all
organized in the same way so if I need
to update something everything stays
totally organized we can also use that
stability for page transforms so react
is really awesome because it helps us
manage state in a really responsible
manner I made this with react and green
sock what green sock has an animation
API react coordinates the state while
green sock coordinates all of the
intermediary values so we're showing the
transition from page to page and all SVG
will stabilize all of our graphics while
we do so so in this example I have this
concept of screens
I'm toggling the screens forward and
then they wrap back around to the to the
beginning screen and then we have a
timeline function that can choreograph
all of the animation but something
that's really cool about the green sock
animation API is this thing called SVG
origin here or this thing called clear
props here the clear props will actually
allow us to remove any inline styles
that are set on that element or that Dom
ref so I can remove those if we need to
recalculate values or put it into
another position so here's another one I
made with view
next which I love view is a front-end
framework that is very similar to react
in that it's the V of MVC you probably
are familiar with it next is a really
quick and easy way to get server-side
rendering with view and it allows you to
do routing and all sorts of code
splitting without stepping outside of a
view file and because we're using SVG
for all of these animations everything
States totally stable Nux also gives us
page transition hooks so we can hook
into the animation and make it different
per page so all the ways that the
mountains are changing and the text is
changing changes per page so if you'd
like to check out the code I have a repo
for it and also a demo site that you
that's live that you can check out too
I'm showing the slide so you can get a
sense of how those j/s hooks work we
have these different page routes and if
you want to plug into them there's a
bunch of different page hooks per page
the one that's really important here is
this transition mode and that's super
cool because when you have a transition
mode in view what it will do is it'll
allow that component to completely
unmount but it'll wait for the animation
to fully fade-out then it will unmount
and the other thing will wait until it's
done so you don't have to write any like
messy callbacks which is what you
usually end up having to do when you
write that kind of code so this is from
code wraps it's a similar concept but
it's built in a different way the fixed
content lies beneath and once we move
the content up it gets revealed and all
at the same time that SVG path is
changed through path data ID and this is
done with animate is not green sock this
pen by Sullivan Nolan uses transitioning
effects and morphing this is back to
green socks morph SVG and you can see
how it's really captivating and again
because we're using SVG stays totally
stable for mobile but we can also use
SVG for the layout itself when we were
making this page for web animation
workshops our branding is all these
triangles so we wanted to make some
interesting page layouts those little
triangles between the sections are
little pieces of SVG where we
said preserve aspect ratio none which
means that it's always gonna scale in
every direction with the container so
usually you don't want that right if
it's like a face or something we don't
want that it's gonna be like and that's
a technical term for that but in terms
of page layout that's exactly what we
want
cool so SVG can also be super tiny if
you look at this HP archive graphic it's
a breakdown of all of what we're
transmitting over the web right all of
the kind of content break down so we've
got a bunch of video we've got a bunch
of fonts and scripts and stylesheets but
images is huge images is two-thirds of
what we deliver over the internet for
everybody so I love this quote you can't
be a web performance expert without
being an image expert it's actually
pretty true if you think about it if you
think about that last graphic if you're
not thinking about the size of your
graphics then you're really doing
yourself a disservice I was asked to I
used to be a consultant before I worked
for Microsoft and this company hired me
because they had ten page 10-second page
load times and just by optimizing the
SVG's on their site I brought the the
site speed down to less than two seconds
that's all of those seconds of
deployment and performance all came from
the graphics so how did I do that
well not all SVG graphics are created
equal we have everything drawn with math
but if you have tons and tons of path
points and you're not not optimizing
correctly it can really bulk your files
so I really like using SVG oMG again
these are like linked up in the slides
if you want to check them out later
SVG oMG is by Jake Archibald it uses a
lot of service workers so if you have a
bunch of settings in it it will remember
the next time you go there which i think
is super cool it uses SVG oh the last
one under the hood which is terminal
based so if you're more comfortable with
your terminal you can use SVG oh but I
suggest you pair it with SVG oh gooey
because the way that you optimize
actually affects the way that that SVG
will look the middle one is Peter Colin
ridges SVG editor it's like a 15 year
old rails app that I just keep in there
cuz like I'm a neck
I like it still probably a little less
useful but really really still kind of
fun I also wrote a post for CSS tricks
called high-performance SVG's that was
all of the process that I went through
to reduce the size of those SVG's for
that consulting gig so in this pen I
have this little draggable thing and
it's a little spaceman and he's standing
on the moon and the cow keeps scaring
him as he goes over the moon and it's
touch enabled for mobile and that whole
SVG is 2 kilobytes so you can do really
kind of cool effects and you know show
really really information interesting
information and have things be super
small so while we're looking at this
let's take a gander at what's happening
under the hood because I ran into a
gotcha when I was trying to build this
so at first I was like oh ok I'm gonna
make this like thing that's like a null
object you know around with this cow and
I can spin that and it can also detect
if there are collisions with like get
pout and get bounding client wrecked or
get B box for that little astronaut head
but then it was firing all the time and
I was like what's going on I think the
browser is wrong no the browser is not
wrong what was happening once I started
you know putting like you know borders
around it and kind of understanding of
this a little bit more is that the
browser doesn't see diagonals the
browser only sees in rectangles so to
give you a better idea of what that
means if you look at the bounding box
stroke of these rotating elements this
is what the Dom sees so I just think
that's crazy like look at that circle
that's so weird
so sometimes in order to debug things
like this you do actually have to think
like the browser not like yourself okay
back to the late of SVG's because there
they have the potential to be so small
SVG is the perfect time to use something
like a loader a lot of loaders are
really ugly and a lot of loaders are
using gifts which are really heavy if
you have a heavy and ugly gift maybe you
should think about updating it this
graphic when I was given this given this
graphic by the designer this is
smashing magazines checkout experience
it was 35 kilobytes and I brought it
down to 6 kilobytes just by optimizing
it correctly and that includes the
animation and everything so SVG's can
make other graphics smaller there's this
thing called SVG JPEG dot SVG and by
this guy named siya and this is not like
a particular graphic that I found but
you can see that just dropping in any
graphic that I had around which is my I
am happy Marge Simpson you know we
brought the file size from 38 kilobytes
to 16 kilobytes just by switching it to
an SVG and creating an image mask over
the kind of repeated you know images if
a bit mask has a lot of the same colored
squares it's still mapping out all of
that territory where an SVG can say like
take the bounds of these things and
don't paint them just show this one
color so that's pretty cool
SVG can be accessible we mentioned this
before there's actually like a ton of
ways that SVG can be accessible and it's
like can be kind of complicated but nine
times out of 10 this is what you're
gonna need in order to make an SVG
accessible so I'm just gonna dive into
that really quick so we write Aria
labeled by and then a title and that
title it has to be the first thing that
follows that SVG tag that title also has
to have a unique ID on it otherwise it
won't be picked up by jaws and in Nvidia
devices just writing title is not enough
we also have roll of presentation on the
SVG itself what that'll do even for your
icons you should be doing this it'll
allow it and screen readers to know that
it's an image and not announce
everything inside if you want it to
announce things inside you move that to
a roll group so that's some of the ways
that you can make it responsive I also
like writing Lang you know whatever
language it is so that you know
somebody's using an screen reader in
another language the computer does the
hard work for them that's pretty cool
so there's a resource with support
charts there's also this article by
Heather that she wrote for CSS tricks
she spent like every weekend going to
the library checking every
different device this whole big labor of
love for the community so definitely
check out that article she did a great
job with it
SVG can be styled like text this is kind
of like not too fancy but something that
you a lot of people kind of come to me
and ask me about so let's cover it real
quick someone on Twitter asked me about
this they made an SVG sprite sheet and
they're not styling it along with the
text they wanted everything you know if
they change that line of text for it to
pick that up so really so this is the
question code I left it exactly how it
was and the secret trick here that you
may or may not know about is that you
change the fill to current color camel
cased and that will just make it reflect
whatever it is so right now I just have
that line with a class that says color
red on it and it's picking up that color
so if you are using SVG icons for your
site that's a really quick way to not
have a headache whenever you're working
with it SVG can bounce we can make a
ball bounce with SVG really easily
without any Lant animation libraries
using a requestanimationframe if we have
this bounce ball bouncing we can use a
little physics to kind of drum up the
bounce of the ball and we can make the
radius bigger and we can do all of that
midstream so I'm using view again here
and there's some info that I'm not sure
showing here but here's the gist of it
we've got data we've got the total like
height of everything we've got the
radius we're incrementing things based
off of a quick event and then we're we
have gravity that increases the vertical
speed horizontal speed increments from
the horizontal position all of these
things I learned from like just pulling
things out of physics books so you don't
have to invent all of this stuff from
scratch you can steal ideas that have
been around for a really long time this
pen by Tiffany ray side is one of my
favorite animations of all time she's
not using any library or anything at all
she's spinning up pieces of the SVG
applying physics and even these like
crazy bounces to to it also she
manipulates the SVG path values when it
hits the wall she's just kind of a
master so if you don't already follow
her on Twitter a code pen you should
definite
go do that SVG can snap in order to
create some you know really really
beautiful effects we're gonna use some
es6 template template literals which
you're probably all familiar with but
just in case you aren't I'm just gonna
say something about them really quickly
previously we had string concatenation
and all of that printed out to this
which was really hard to read and it was
kind of ugly and it was kind of
error-prone because it was hard to read
and now we have awesome template
literals that when you put things in
backticks
we can just manipulate strings really
really readily and what does that have
to do with SVG well SVG all of those
paths inside in Venice Fiji are really
just a bunch of strings of commands and
they have these curve values and all of
the letters mean a certain thing and
draw certain kind of curves and create
certain kind of paths so I really like
this kind of path Explorer tool if
you're not familiar with the way that
SVG works you can go and play with this
I also wrote about it in my book if you
want to you know something that's a
little bit more traditional and if we
know enough about how those curves are
made updating them is very simple with
something like template literals when
we're building out these paths we start
with a move - and then we can create
those curves by using things like C and
Q so we give it a handle and then we
give it another point and the computer
draws a curve for us how cool is that
you can like plot three points and the
computer draws a curve I just think
that's great so that's really neat and
then we can plot the points we have a
bunch of different coordinate values
that were updating and it's so flexible
we can make effects like this
so you might have noticed that that SPG
was distorting at the end there so let's
kind of cover distortion really quickly
and big and how you can do that
so distortion filters are really awesome
there was this great code code drops
demo with a bunch of buttons and
definitely the most you know impressive
technique was you hit a button and this
little ripple effect came out and what
they're doing in order to create that is
they're using a filter called turbulence
and you can animate this filter in
JavaScript you can't do it in CSS it's
not an animate scible property we're
kind of like hacking the speck here and
manipulating it because there's just a
bunch of numbers but I would say that
from manipulating filters and pushing
the doms boundaries and stuff and doing
things I'm not supposed to do I would
suggest setting the filter on a timer
like applying it when you need it and
taking it off when you don't because it
is performance and sensitive it's not
really hardware accelerated so we can
make things like this pool and that's
pretty fun because the way that this is
done is by applying that filter and
using an image to distort anything
that's beneath it so we can have tons
and tons of path values like you see
here everything under the pool is also
getting updated too and we can do it
really really simply all we're doing is
we're taking that distortion filter in
that image and we're basically making it
scale down hit the wall and scaling up
and we're also animating the filter so
we can do like really really crazy
effects and when I made this pan I
wasn't really thinking about like the
political climate so it's a weird one to
show but we can by animating filters we
can also make things like a realistic
candle that's drawn with math that's
really really fun in order to make this
I have a few different pieces that I
just kind of traced off of a candle
photo so I just made this in Illustrator
and then made a gradient that's attached
to it and then I
they're not actually blue but I have a
bunch of different path values that I'm
going to set on a for loop and I'm gonna
morph between those path values for each
second and plot them along a time line
but I also am using a filter and it's
this GUI filter that Lucas beber created
so he has some prior art here he's
actually using this with divs you can
make an SVG filter and apply it to HTML
you don't only have to use SVG so that's
pretty cool so a lot of people use this
kind of GUI effect it's a blur filter in
a contrast filter applied at the same
time so yeah we cannot because you know
that standard deviation of the filter is
just using numbers we can have
JavaScript update those numbers
requestanimationframe knows how to
update numbers so we can do that we go
through all of the path values and then
we've got a little math dot random
opacity because nature is just a little
unpredictable and then we can use that
effect to create smoke with math SVG can
do on the fly logo adjustment this demo
was made by leav aroo-whoo if you don't
follow her already you should probably
go do so because she makes all sorts of
crazy great things but basically you're
allowed to update these logos on the fly
which i think is super great if you have
to collaborate with a designer it keeps
on not making their mind up and you're
like they're like Oh change it out here
oh no it like fat is in oh no flat is in
you can kind of make all of these things
really really adjustable so you don't
have to keep changing things up and she
made this with a tool called MA though
that she built that's basically so that
you can drum up sites using HTML and CSS
with very little JavaScript which is not
very useful for us but I'm pretty sure
that almost everyone in this audience
has a family member that's like hey can
you make me a web site and if you do
this is a really good thing to show them
because they with just a little bit of
training they can make their own website
and you can get on to your real life
work
SVG can draw itself too so let's say we
have a shape and that's the stroke of
that shape is dashed
but we make the - all the way around
that entire shape it's the length of the
entire shape that offset the offset
between those two dashes is animatable
so we can have an SVG draw all onto the
page just using CSS or something so I
made this pen to kind of celebrate New
Year's and there's like you know the
fireworks are that kind of idea and pew
and yeah that's this pen by Chris Gannon
is also really awesome he does this that
same effects if you don't follow him you
should go follow him because he I think
he's just pretty much a genius he's also
doing this with clip path it's super
cool you can also interact with an SVG
we can manipulate it and interact with
it on the fly as well so if since it has
a navigable navigable Dom you can do all
sorts of things with it again I'm using
view here to like update the text and
make random lines and allow the user to
kind of play with the SVG graphic as
much as they want to I can also animate
it if I want to and have them be in
charge of that as well and I made this
demo too long so we're all gonna watch
it so it's gonna play the animation but
the coolest part of all of this is I'm
gonna play this animation it's still a
graphic so I can still download it and
it's going to respect all of the
positions that were set during that
animation so even though I'm animating
it it's still in all of those places
it's still a graphic that they can hand
out to their friends or something so
here inside the HTML template we can
create some semantic form elements and
then we can bind them to these methods
where we're creating and kind of
drumming up pieces of the SVG on the fly
we use s we can use SVG to respond to
things that the blog that the browser is
doing so we have this like little Wally
pen I don't know if you've seen the
movie Wally but I really like it
he has a little cockroach friend and
he's you know kind of reaching out for
him every
the user moves across the page so what
we have here and we have a bit more code
than that but basically we have these at
mousemove events and I've created an
entire timeline for him reaching his
arms out complete with eases and then I
plot that along that progress of the
timeline along with the coordinate so
the user can control all of that and it
stays really really lifelike so in order
to make that pen we had to clip and mask
things so SVG can clip and mask things
SVG offers this thing called clip path
which is really nice because if you
looked at his arms they had to kind of
reach out from somewhere right I can't
just keep tucking everything behind over
everything else in order to make it look
realistic it has to clip out parts of
his arm so we were able to do that with
clip paths and if you use something
called mask you can use opacity so clip
paths will just kind of respect the
geometry but something like a mask we
can create something with an you know
like a gift masking with all of these
SVG patterns and you know slowly unveil
them we create a mask and F's and and
put inside of it the image that we want
to use and then we have we apply it to a
rect that also has a pattern associated
with it so I learned this technique from
yoke cyl who has like a whole bunch of
pens like this that are super super
awesome she also has the most
comprehensive you know collection of SVG
and CSS clip paths so if you need to
learn about them or you're confused
about them this is all like interactive
and you can play with it and the code is
open source I also kept getting confused
between the difference between clip
paths and masks so I wrote a CSS tricks
article that you can look at too that
defines the differences between them CSS
has tricks has pretty good SEO so I knew
I could just go look at my own resource
again and again if I got confused again
and since SVG also has text you can have
that clip that masking applied a text
and do things like have your users
update text to this pen by Knoll Delgado
is probably the most famous and also my
favorite example of this clipping and
masking that's paired with animation
SVG can signify something changing so I
kept going in between different time
zones for my work and I you know
couldn't remember where all my
co-workers were what time it was and I
could have just made a dial that just
showed what time things were but by
changing the SVG and making that dial
that associates that change in time I
get a better sense of whether or not
it's day or night and I can ping them or
not and they're probably with their kids
or something like that
but while I was working on this
something interesting I found was I used
to use this thing called moment jeaious
that kind of allowed me to work with
time data and understand where everybody
was you know in terms of like daylight
savings time but there's actually a
native method called to local time
string that offers all of these defaults
like hours and minutes and all sorts of
things so that actually respects all of
those daylight savings time so you can
eliminate a big library like moment you
can use SVG's view box as a camera this
is one of my favorites you might already
know this but when you have something
like a graphic when SVG is plotting all
of those points to draw those
coordinates it's doing so on a big piece
of graph paper basically and that piece
of graph paper is endless it's just this
giant coordinate system and in order to
see inside of that SVG and know where to
plot those coordinates and what you're
looking at you have a thing called a
view box and the view box is made up of
4 values 0 0 that's x and y where to
start it off and then width and height
so if I wanted to update this view box
to just look at these little houses or
something I would have to you know
update them to 215 1 by 160 42 by 20 so
SVG also has a native method called get
B box and that will return this object
that has X Y width and height for
anything that's inside the SVG that's
cool that sounds a little familiar that
might be what we need to maybe enemy
or you know update it on the fly so here
I'm just you know using that to update
the view box and then if I take that out
it will go right back to where it was so
I'm just setting the attributes based on
that so then we can do something like
this data visualization where we're
zooming in on a certain country in order
to show different pieces of information
and again because it's SVG it's all
totally scalable for mobile and it's so
small because it's just one path that's
drawn we can also make a flowchart I'm
basically this is just a giant SVG and
we're just like moving things based on
the user input and like then people can
pick a certain thing and then they can
go to you know a different kind of
output so we can make you know
interactive flowcharts this one is
really cool this is like a game that
somebody made updating the view box
where they're like placing little
household items and stuff but we can do
better we can do like a big game so so
let's make a game and that will be the
last thing we do this afternoon so if we
have a game about a hipster elephant
that's going to go get tacos but his
friends keep texting him to change plans
and you're supposed to try to go get the
tacos but avoid the text messages and
like there's margaritas for extra bonus
points
oops so you can basically move this guy
around and like your heart meter goes up
and down and if you lose the game you
become hangry and you have to watch a
movie you already saw and if you win the
game you could tweet out your score it's
based on real-life events so how do we
use SVG in order to create this we're
using react to manage all the state for
that application if you know how to
manage say for an application you can
probably already make a game too so
we're using SVG threeways we have it
directly inline in the HTML for loops we
have background images for things like
tacos we're not really you know updating
the tacos we're just kind of throwing
them across so they don't have to do
anything super special and we have
things that are inline directly in react
so let's look at that last one really
quickly
if we have this is a slightly older pen
so yes I know I'm using react create
class I wouldn't use that now I would
use class extends so if we have the
initial state of that score that's at
500 and then you know we're setting the
game to start because they can play it
again they can you know get to the end
and decide to replay so we're setting
the score back to 500 if they do so we
don't want them to have too much you
know winning too much or losing too much
and then we have this update score that
will either like end the game or win the
game if it gets to a certain amount but
then and my highlighter is not on this
it's on the dots but it should be on the
heart meter and that heart meter we're
passing down this dot state score so you
might have noticed that heart meter at
the top of the at the top of the game
that was kind of keeping track of our
score so basically we have this SVG and
that SVG is actually really really big
because I want to use whole numbers for
this I don't want to use like twenty
seven point two five or something to
update the score when he's a thousand or
zero so it's really big and then we have
the weight that's this stop prop score
and in our racks in SVG in order to
update it we have an X Y width and
height just like the bounding box so we
can update that on the fly and because
it's SVG we can make it super small then
for the size of the screen that we need
and on desktop it's a certain size and
on mobile it's a different size with
media queries all of that and we didn't
even get to any data visualization I
wrote a book about SVG animation this is
not my book this is my friend making fun
of me I don't have a man blob animal
that's not even my last name I do have a
real or any book I think I have like a
fancy chicken or something that's cool
yeah thank you so much for coming today
I appreciated
thank you so much Sarah those animations
totally blew my mind and I love how you
shout it out so many other creators in
your talk weight us Fred the love yeah
yeah there's some a lot of them we have
time for one quick question what
resources would you recommend to get
started creating awesome SVG's like the
ones you showed yeah actually I think a
misconception that a lot of people have
is that you have to be a designer in
order to make things with SVG you don't
there's tons of free SVG's online that
you can go play with free pick with a K
no CK free pick com has tons of free
vectors that you can use the noun
project also has a bunch of free vectors
so you can just you know download them
and start playing with them and
animating them and manipulating them
awesome thank you Sarah definitely go
buy her book if you want to learn more
[Applause]